salut mes petits poulets non je suis pas
en train de craquer enfin si un petit
peu mais ça n'a rien à voir c'est par
rapport aux soldes énigme d'hier que je
vous appelle mes petits poulets
puisqu'il hier on parlait de poules etc
avant de vous donner l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui je vous donne la réponse
de l'énigme d'hier
si vous l'avez pas vu regardez-le avant
d'écouter la réponse donc combien
d'oeuvres vont prendre 400 poule en
quatre jours
réponse deux sens puisque 800 poules
pondent 800 ce en huit jours ça veut
dire que 800 poules pondent 100e en un
jour donc deux fois moins de poule en
une journée vont prendre deux fois moins
2 50 et donc en 4 fois plus de temps
quatre jours quatre fois 50 200 l était
pas hyper compliqué je regarderai le
ratio de pouce en l'air pour voir
combien d'entre vous avez trouvé la
bonne réponse par contre l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui elle est plus coton mais
alors pour moi c'est le plus intéressant
énigmes va énigmes compliqué je vous le
dis direct vous arrivez au purgatoire
ah oui alors désolé je vous ai pas
précisé vous êtes mort pour cette énigme
vous arrivez au purgatoire est là devant
vous il ya deux personnes identique en
tout point même visage même temps n'y a
pas un détail qui les différencie même
pas dans la voix rien derrière chacune
de ces deux personnes il ya une porte
tout les deux identiques
rien qui les différencie à rien mais
vous vous avez un parchemin sur lequel
il est écrit l'un des deux est dieu il
est devant la porte du paradis et dit
toujours la vérité systématiquement
l'autre et le diable il est devant la
porte de l'enfer et il ment tout le
temps quoi qu'il arrive il ment vous
avez le droit de poser une seule
question à un des deux uniquement et sa
réponse devra vous permettre de choisir
la porte du paradis
sauf si vous préférez aller en enfer
mais ça c'est votre choix en tout cas en
imposant une seule question à l'un des
deux vous devrez en mesure de déterminer
quelle est la porte du paradis la porte
de l'enfer
je vous conseille de faire un petit
schéma quand même sur un papier pour
essayer de résoudre cette énigme
elle est très compliqué c'est mon prof
de maths qui me l'a fait quand j'étais
en première j'ai passé un ou deux jours
de sujets pas trouvé la solution je vous
le dis pour vous rassurer sur le fait
qu'elle soit pas évidente
par contre c'est très intéressant de
chercher ça vous permettra encore mieux
d'apprécier la réponse derrière si
jamais vous trouvez la solution ne l'a
dit pas dans les commentaires ce serait
trop dommage par contre vous pouvez me
le faire savoir en laissant un petit
pouce en l'air comme ça on verra le
nombre de pouces en l'air et donc le
nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la
réponse
profitez bien du soleil passer un bel
été et rendez vous demain à 17h châu
à